maybe she saw your pubes once and she's
like all I see are Judy's cube that
sounds like what a principal would say
hey guys welcome to the other show again
my name is Chris I'm Sarah and we're
here with Drew and Hellena
and Jimmy and of ours who play a couple
of the instigates in this episode we
were very excited for this episode to
air and to like shoot this episode
because it really made us laugh and you
guys are so funny in there thank you
those characters that are like bitchy
gay guys is such a stereotype so to play
someone who's like they have no like
they were just really kind so great it's
so it was so refreshing to be like yeah
they're they're not bad I am yeah yeah
I'm using them all you do is get naked
and post pictures and have sex with each
other we don't have sex with each other
what why don't you I had to go through
an unfollow a bunch of these guys
because I would just like be out in the
world and I would be technically looking
at porn
I'd be like hiding my phone like over in
the corner I was like I can't just be
looking at a man's full butt at the
doctor's office waiting right we follow
one and yes and then in a year you're
like this is porn I'm scrolling that's
like when we were like researching ish
the instigate culture any profile I went
to was like followed by Drew
are you Wow strong is wondering about
the model oh yes I'll talk about it here
you see beautiful people like that in
person and it's like truly shocking it
was shocking in when I watched it
unbelievable I feel like I wanted to ask
him but I didn't quite know how to
phrase it like what is it like to look
like you but he would have killed her
though like clearly was originally gonna
say we like to mean like I liked
actually one of my favorite things to
shoot as well because we shot that in
Madison Square Park like in the early
early morning I'm shooting in New York
City and like iconic areas like that in
the morning they're empty yeah you sort
of watched the city come alive while
you're standing there and it's really
amazing let's see that body wait where's
the body this is sort of an embarrassing
thing but maybe it will spark something
but you go on a date with that guy Paul
from Rolling Stone we were like oh
what's a good douchey Twitter handle for
a guy like this and we used my real one
from high school because it was so do G
my aim screen name in high school was
king of sarcasm like I am pretty
sarcastic in fact I'm the king of it I
had just done a production of West Side
Story and I was baby John and so my
scream was baby John five isn't that
just like okay it's sad you do why baby
Johnny literally like I was baby John
well yeah it is kind of like when you
are in high school like one thing you've
done you make your ins a big deal yeah
yeah I was a big deal in West Side Story
and it wasn't my screen name but my
class ring says a big deal on it oh wow
West Side Story
mine was belle of the ball because of a
Guster song where that is a lyric 103
which is where in the song that lyric
first appears but the Bell was filled
with an e because that was my favorite
Disney Princess there's so many layers
sarah in high school when like you are
deep girl I'd be like yeah mine was
complicated because I'm a big x-men fan
okay
so I wanted a X in it and then my mom
had a porcelain figure of a swan oh he's
just looked like the lip and it was
there so I was like Swan X and it was
like SWA and e^x and it sounds like a
cleaner SWA and e^x and it was like
Swannack you did like like what they do
like bad writing and comedies everybody
my name is Bob trees let's do like a
funny one oh yeah good yeah and good
three two one wait how did you guys pose
so we asked you guys to show us pictures
that you had posted on the internet
where you were being a thirsty okay that
is good yeah that was me like in 2016
this is all we were like send the
picture that's like we could kind of
like laugh about cuz there's two thirsty
in it and we got through like no I would
love to see that on my scroll I'm really
repressed I think so I'm like but I
still want to participate I'm like okay
we asked drew for a thirsty photo and
it's him as a snap zoom in so much to
see anybody but that's what you said you
were like if someone's gonna work for it
really zoom in you will see a blurry
kind of good chess okay Jimmy's is good
this is also good
[Applause]
this is justin theroux and by the way
when you post a thirsty photo your
thirst gets Coe wench people like that
[Music]
you